hi there steve kaufman here again day
64.
let me just check here
yeah day 64.
so a little over 26 days to go
um what i want to talk about today is
the fact that language learning
is a personal thing
unless you're enrolled in a class and
you have to write an exam but even then
hopefully it's your own decision to go
there it's very much a personal thing we
don't learn languages for other people
we learn them for ourselves now there
are exceptions you may require a
language for a job
you may require a language to become a
citizen in a country
but even there if you aren't doing it
for yourself you probably won't succeed
so i think it's very important that we
do we learn languages for our own
reasons motives and satisfaction so
that's the first point so i'm enjoying
my involvement in my korean challenge
and my commitment and the challenge was
to put more effort into language
learning than i have been doing in the
past and to concentrate on one
language
more or less i have done that
uh the last 15 20 days i haven't been
that's my wife by the way playing in the
background she's getting better and
better on the piano all the time
um
last little while ever since we went to
san diego
five days there didn't do much then we
have all these events in ukraine so i'm
listening to a lot of russian
uh
so i haven't been applying myself quite
as
conscientiously to the korean
as i did in the first
20 30 days
but i am gonna try to get back to here
again today i had to go to a funeral it
was quite a drive out there i'm finally
back home tonight the
canucks are on tv i'm gonna watch them
again so i don't know how much i'll get
done today but tomorrow i'm gonna
definitely try to sock in four or five
hours
because i have this commitment to the
challenge and i think the commitment in
the challenge is about trying to do more
than we normally do
it's not a commitment that i will reach
any particular level although i think i
said at the beginning that i was hoping
to reach a strong b1
level
um
who knows i've still got 25 days to go
not that i actually remember what i said
back then but mostly
the challenge is about everyone
challenging themselves challenging
themselves to do more because if you are
more active with the language you will
improve
now there were some interesting comments
to yesterday's
uh video where i put up a video of
myself talking to julian so i'm going to
go over some of these and answer the
questions
first of all we have a comment here
saying very good steve but you should be
better
because you are a language expert no i
don't agree
i think it takes time to learn a
language
and you just have to put in the time and
there is no should in language learning
whatever i have achieved in korean
that is what i can achieve given the
amount of effort that i put into it
period and other people may achieve more
or less and that's what they should
achieve there's no objective you should
achieve
then someone says you've never conversed
with a korean guy they're all girls
that's not true in fact i've conversed
with more korean guys tutors at link
however the quality of the video this
the
skype
camera connection and the sound quality
was best with joo hyun now i'm going to
be talking to a new
male tutor at link this friday and if
the connections are good
then that's what i will put up as a
video
then we had a fellow here said
you are just talking steve you are not
really having a conversation i've
noticed this behavior when you speak to
people in korean you don't really engage
the other person in conversation you
tend to just speak like an ongoing
soliloquy whereby you do all the talking
giving others little or no chance to
respond to what you're saying you do not
engage the person a conversation is a
two-way exchange is it not you speak the
other person responds
you listen
then you respond
blah blah blah in other words i should
let the other person talk more well
and then another person came along and
said
yes i agree i've noticed it before when
you were at the dry cleaner you did all
the talking and it's very important to
have real conversations with people and
so forth and so on
um okay
yes i tend to talk a lot
uh second of all as i said in one of my
earlier videos
i understand what i'm saying much better
than i understand what people are saying
to me
i said that earlier and so it's probably
a bit of a defensive mechanism
that
when i have something that i know that i
can say
i will say it
once the korean person starts talking
i'm not so sure i'm going to understand
what they say
so it might be that
and as i explained in my comment
in response to that first person
our instructions to a tutor at link when
i tutor english
i feel that my job is to
somehow
induce that person to speak because we
do a lot of listening listening to
content in our lessons listening and
reading so this is an opportunity to
speak and the more i speak the more i
display my shortcomings the tutor then
makes notes of these and sends me a
report which i import into link and
study so that is kind of our learning
strategy so what i put up there was
a
typical lesson
at link
but
since uh there seems to be an interest
in seeing whether or not i'm able to
participate in more of a balanced
conversation i will make a point in my
next interview
of
trying to make it more balanced and let
that person speak more
i don't think as was suggested here that
i deliberately interrupted the tutor
i've spoken to julion many many times
and her strategy as a tutor is to get me
to speak and just let me speak she
rarely interrupts me she just lets me
speak however
i think what's important here is you
know a number of these comments were
saying you should do this you should do
that
i think that we learn languages for our
own purposes
i don't know what i'm going to achieve
in korea but already
the fact that i have discovered this
wonderful podcast which i mentioned so
many times by kim yong-ha
the fact that i am enjoying these
podcasts in korean
that i've kind of
partly understood and worked my way
through five or six of them and that
there's a total of 53 in this series and
i'm having them all transcribed and that
i will continue to do those until the
end of the 53 podcast where and through
this process i will learn a great deal
about world literature a great deal
about kim jung-ha and how he thinks and
i will tremendously improve my korean at
least my my vocabulary and my ability to
understand korean i think
from my experience with that as a base
when i have the opportunity to speak
more i will also improve my speaking but
you know i haven't and it is also true
that if i'm listening to something
on a theme where i have access to the
transcript and i listen to it
and following the the sort of a train of
thought it's easier to understand that
then
then when you listen to someone who
could say anything and you're not
familiar with
you know the way people react in a
a korean back and forth conversation so
you you basically don't understand it's
like i said when i was in that korean
restaurant they said uh you know uh
muslim
you need something even though i know
the word pdo like to need i wasn't
expecting that i wasn't able to respond
i didn't understand it so there is no
question
that if i were to spend let's say for
the next 25 days if i were going if i
were to go down to the korean cultural
center and engage korean people
in conversations for two hours on a
variety of subjects that my ability to
respond in conversations and to express
myself wouldn't improve dramatically
however
i'm not going to do that because
i have other things that i have to do i
can't find the time to do that i have my
hockey i have my office i have my family
and social life and
following the events in ukraine and so
on so
mainly what i'm going to be able to do
what is easier for me to organize is to
continue
studying kim jong-un's podcast because i
find it enjoyable
and it's not obvious that i could find
people to make conversation with me
uh down at the korean cultural center or
whatever but i will try to step up my uh
conversations at link but you know
i think it's very important
i'm doing this because i enjoy it once
i should do this or should be at this
level
then it's no longer enjoyment it's an
obligation
and
you know i'm not in that position i'm in
the position of doing things that i
enjoy doing
so
i just thought i would comment on that i
think we don't need to put unnecessary
uh burdens on ourselves
and we should try to focus as i always
say focus on doing the things that we
enjoy doing
and
if we enjoy what we're doing we have
already achieved the goal
thanks for listening